you
everybody's talking about how terribly
important innovation is people are
defining innovation I think the best
taxonomy of innovation I've seen as a
paper that's about five years old now if
you're curious about about breaking
innovation down into its into its
components there's a paper called Darwin
and the demon by geoffrey moore which is
essentially a taxonomy of innovation and
it tells you it describes and breaks
innovation down into topics like service
innovation business process innovation
product innovation and so on and the
fundamental message you might imagine is
the type of innovation you work on is
less important than the fact that you're
really really good at that type of
innovation and that it's consistent with
your company's key business and
strategic initiatives right people tend
to think of Apple as the sort of you
know sort of the pinnacle of innovation
arguably they're just one type of
innovation and that is and that is
product innovation so everybody's
talking about what innovation is it's
always good to start with with
definitions for the purpose of this
discussion innovation is creation
resulting from study and experimentation
and I want to make a distinction here if
you come up with a cute idea you put it
on a wiki you throw in a in a virtual
suggestion box somewhere it might be
very creative it might be cute it might
be clever but it's not innovation for
for legitimate innovation you need some
sort of instantiation of the idea
whether it's a sketch or storyboard
related to some new service you're
thinking of or a simple prototype of
what you've created or a physical layout
of some new space that you're thinking
about you need to have some sort of
instantiation for your creative idea in
order for to actually foster innovation
what I want to talk about is over the
next hour and what I want to hear from
you about when I introduce some of the
ideas is some specific methods to foster
a culture of innovation in your
organization and as I want to talk about
the how rather than the what or the or
the why first let me just give you one
background slide I'm director of
Technology Strategy at IDEO we are a
just so that you understand where I'm
coming from and what my perspective is
we're professional services firm
about 20 years old now I joined actually
when the company was had had just been
created as a merger as well as a result
of a merger with two other three other
firms and our exclusive mission
statement is that we help our clients to
innovate as a professional services firm
and we do that by taking a human
centered approach to design of products
and services and experiences people pay
us to do three things people pay us to
gain insights into populations of
stakeholders they might be internal
people at an organization they might be
external customers for example one of my
projects now has to do with better
understanding the needs of home PC users
in China all right second people pay us
to visualize solutions opportunities
since the solutions based on the
inspiration that comes from that field
research and third people pay us to help
them redesign their organization using
methods of design thinking to help them
foster more sustainable cultures of
innovation all right so what in
preparing this what David and I agreed
would be most interesting are to
highlight some of the methods of what we
like to call design thinking and the
power of design thinking to drive
innovation in an organization okay
what's the big idea with design thinking
there are any number of ways to innovate
there are any number of ways to be
creative one way to do that is to look
at some of the most creative professions
in the world that are applied okay look
at advertising look at architecture look
at industrial design and ask yourself
what are some of the mental constructs
that these people have how do they think
how do they how do they experience the
world and then to roll those approaches
those behaviors that some of the most
creative people have into a set of
principles that we call design thinking
and that's what I want to talk about to
you this afternoon
what's design thinking all about design
thinking is about creating the right
kind of interdisciplinary teams of what
we call t-shaped people we'll get to
that in a minute that's one of the key
points that I want to make this morning
and the second key thing that I want to
emphasize is the second area around
design
thinking which is to observe to become
inspired and to and to and to synthesize
observations to come up with actionable
observations or actionable opportunities
the third principle of design thinking
is to use your inspiration gained from
the field to visualize new opportunities
and the fourth is to make appropriate
use of prototypes and I'm going to
define prototype for you to help drive
forward the innovation process so we'll
go into each of these in detail but I
want to make a very key point here and I
think it was mentioned in the in the
blurb that summarizes this talk what's
the subtext here okay I'm talking about
I'm talking about how to be creative how
to be innovative up here the subtext
here is innovation is absolutely not
some innate talent that people either
have or they don't that's this old
archaic way of thinking about innovation
and creativity and I urge you to reject
it I completely reject that that that
that that notion innovation is
absolutely a learn about skill as with
any other skill like playing piano or or
learning mathematics different people
have different appear to have different
levels of innate aptitudes towards
creativity okay I know a guy who's a VC
and he has like a new idea and it's a
pretty good idea like every eight
minutes you know I call it the Carter
timer you know cuz this guy Carter has
these new ideas constantly that's great
the key point I want to make is anyone
can learn the team-based sport of
innovation how many of you worked with
advertising firms there's this there's
this old archaic notion in many
advertising firms especially if you like
watch madmen or something like that it's
still based on this where the term
creative is a noun if you guys run into
this they use the word creatives to
describe these people in backrooms and
Madison Avenue you never really meet
they've got weird shoes and messed up
hair and stuff like that and you meet
the well-groomed Account Manager in an
accounting firm I see some people
nodding you've been through this and the
premise there is the creatives are
people that you can't possibly be in
they're locked away because they have
some they have something you don't
reject that it's it's it's it's bunk
I've been in this field for 20 years I
can tell you these are these are
learnable skills how do you learn them
what do you do step one
assemble the right team assemble an
innovation team that is both
interdisciplinary and foster the
creation of t-shaped people let's take
those things in reverse order
what's a t-shaped person a t-shaped
person and we use the metaphor of a tea
literally a t-shaped person is someone
who has a depth of expertise okay you
know no-nothing middle managers are gone
they disappeared in the 80s right you
need to know something you're deep in
accounting you're deep in finance you're
all about engineering you're an
electrical engineer you're a software
engineer you're a chip designer okay you
know something you've got a depth of
expertise that is your path to move
upwards into the professional into the
professional world okay
what's the leg of the tea the leg of the
tea is not being all things to all
people the leg of the tea is honest
appreciation and empathy for the other
disciplines okay so I'm talking here
about a software engineer who's really
really good at writing code that has an
honest appreciation for example of the
needs and the motivations of a marketing
person and a sales person and a quality
engineer all right when you're hiring
and when you're growing talent as
leaders in Silicon Valley or elsewhere
when you're interviewing look for people
who use the pronoun we more than they
use the pronoun I okay look for people
who are proud of their achievements
primarily by highlighting their own
contributions as part of a team of
people that they were really proud of
okay that's an early indicator that
you're looking at a t-shaped individual
okay you will not get much in the way of
innovation from people who talk about
how smart they are and they might be
super smart and sort of subtly devalue
the contributions of other people that
were around them on the team or their
boss or something like that okay so this
sort of t-shaped behavior is is really
essential for successful innovation
teams okay I spend a lot of time working
with David David fundamentally on a
program that he and
work together last summer he was
fundamentally the business guy in a
program we'll talk more about that in a
minute
but the fact is he had an honest
appreciation for the needs of the
manufacturing engineers who were worried
about the cost of the product that he
put out okay so it's depth of expertise
in an area and what I would call an
honest and sincere empathy for other
domains that are outside your own that
can be cultivated in people that can
also be looked for in the hiring process
all right
so what do we recommend for an
innovation team you want to do something
innovative you're you're you're thinking
about you're thinking about next
generation data services for smartphones
you're thinking about you're thinking
about some really new exciting renewable
energy programs you're thinking about
fostering you know products to decrease
the cost of healthcare okay they're just
a tremendous number of wonderful domains
that I'm sure you're either in or will
be moving into when you graduate that
are that are exciting and that all call
for tremendous innovation a little hard
to read let me talk you through the text
here I submit that that in early stages
for innovation you need three voices on
an innovation team okay and those voices
come from t-shaped people who are open
ultimately to unifying into a single
voice in a single direction okay they're
people who have strong points of view
themselves but appreciate the existence
of other people's point of view all
right so what have we got we've got the
voice of business and business viability
the voice of technology and the voice of
the human this the voice of the of the
stakeholder either the end customer or
the person somewhere else in the supply
chain who is who is who is an important
stakeholder in the business or policy
success of your endeavor all right let's
talk about each of those let's talk
about business briefly and then one of
the things that David recommended we
talk in some detail about how as
business leaders you can manage
technical people to help foster
innovation in highly technical
organizations okay but let's start with
business what is the role of a business
person on a on an innovation team okay
before we're getting into the details of
implementation before we're into all the
sort of classic product management areas
of rollout and so on okay a business
person and a lot of you may play this
role some of them those of you that are
still in school may play this role in
the future a business person does two
things on an innovation team first of
all
a business person helps acquaint every
single person on an innovation team and
for a small innovation team we're often
talking three to ten people helps
acquaint and familiarize everyone
adequately with the business landscape
around the innovation challenge that
you're facing okay and this leads to the
second mythbuster statement I want to
make which is that there's this myth
that innovation thrives in what is
called a greenfield absent any
boundaries that's just wrong and that's
another notion that you should reject if
you've ever heard it innovation thrives
on constraints and this is this goes to
a topic that you mentioned a little
earlier some of the most constrained
cultures and indeed constrained
businesses tiny broke startups with
hardly any money there are cultures
India is one of them we're opening up an
office in Mumbai it's what we're seeing
some of the most creative most
impressive creativity and innovation
coming out of India that I've ever seen
in my entire life and a lot of that has
to do with scarcities in India driving
really exciting innovation it has to do
with energy scarcity and resource
scarcity and and and in capital market
scarcity and so on so keep in mind that
in general boundaries and constraints
and limits are the friend of innovation
okay
they help drive innovation in any
program from the outset should be
operating under a clear set of
boundaries and constraints from a
business person on the current business
landscape everybody on innovation team
should understand things like current
market segmentation in the competitive
landscape and the pricing and costing
models in the ultimate marketing plan
okay so David on our program part of his
role was to act as an ambassador to the
IDEO team helping everybody develop the
sort of shared conversant around
business issues okay
the other role that a business person
plays on many
innovation teams depending on the nature
of what you're doing is acting as a
strategic adviser to the external
partners that you're working with ok so
again using the project that was related
to crafting the home crafting market
that David and I worked on over the
summer David also acted as a strategic
adviser to our client building some
quantitative spreadsheets to help better
understand the potential of the
proposals we were coming up with as
compared to their existing product line
all right so that's what I mean in brief
we could talk about this you know for
hours all afternoon but in brief that's
what a that's what a business person
does the inward-facing role of a
business person is is to help
familiarize everybody on an
interdisciplinary team with business
issues the outward facing role is to act
as a strategic adviser to partners as
appropriate now let's talk in a little
more detail about about technologists on
innovation teams this is something that
David and I agreed would be an
interesting thing to cover it's very
likely that all of you will be in a
position of managing technologists and
wanting to gain maximum value from
technologists engineers scientists
technicians okay on innovation programs
I want to make a couple of points here
the first is I'd like to draw a
distinction between technology push and
technology pull and just to cut to the
chase I submit that the winners and this
has been consistent this is one of the
few consistent things over the 20 years
I've had an idea where so much has
changed consistently the winners are the
ones who create a healthy tension
between technology push and technology
pull and consider both simultaneously
what does that mean in a little more
detail technology push is a philosophy
which says let's take our existing
assets let's take our intellectual
property let's take technology that
we've developed and let's understand new
domains of opportunity for that
technology all right let's identify new
areas around the globe
new geographic regions that might be
interested let's identify new vertical
markets where we might apply that
technology let's identify let's identify
new scenarios of use okay this is an
incredibly important and viable business
model in and of itself in isolation
who's the professor David that season
who so professor Andy Radcliffe sees
tech push as core to the majority if not
all of the of the of the tech startups
coming out of Silicon Valley okay my
personal poster child for technology
pushes Qualcomm some of you may have
worked with them there are a telecom
company based out of San Diego they have
fantastic technologies one is called
CDMA it's a wireless protocol all right
Qualcomm said to themselves we've got
this fantastic wireless protocol let's
push it into new domains we were
starting to saturate the United States
let's push into Korea let's push into
China okay we're starting to saturate
the telecom market in general let's push
into new vertical markets let's push
into medical instruments and devices
body-worn devices like cardiac monitors
that broadcast their telemetry back to
Mission Control centers okay it's been a
hugely successful model for them now
let's contrast tech push with technology
pull technology poll says let's forget
about technology let's forget about what
we own let's put business models and
human beings at the center of our
thinking okay and let's think about
important and relevant trends
demographic economic social political
religious let's think about important
emerging trends and let's ask ourselves
what technology might be brought to bear
on those trends that is relevant or more
typically what aggregation of technology
might be brought to bear on those trends
that is that is relevant to this
fundamental consumer demand this
fundamental human need okay poster child
here longtime client of ideos Procter &
Gamble okay sure they employ thousands
of scientists but they don't typically
start with a given science with a given
technology that they've developed like a
chemical formulation and explore how to
apply it they typically start with
fundamental human needs like people hate
ironing
or you know people want their clothes to
last longer and they ask themselves what
technology can be brought it can be
brought to bear okay so the interesting
thing is if you go back and look at my
two poster children for these two trends
what's Qualcomm doing Qualcomm is making
a very hard push he's making a very hard
move into technology Pohl Qualcomm is
hiring market researchers and
anthropologists and human factors people
like crazy in order to better understand
some of the global social and economic
trends and they're coming up with a
philosophy that includes organic
development of Technology licensing and
and out sourced technology development
with the view towards increasing their
quotient around technology poll and
similarly Procter & Gamble right about
the time I started working with them
which is a which is about twelve years
ago they're moving this way okay they
had developed a certain technology for D
wrinkling garments and they said to them
and what they essentially said the idea
was where else can this technology be
applied how can we push this technology
into new domains and and and maximize
the investment that we've already put
into this technology okay so let me just
let me just show you a couple of
examples of technology Poland I think
are significant all of you have probably
seen technology push what's what's hot
these days there's a there's a
technology that you've probably heard
about if not you will called Near Field
Communication NFC this is an important
enabling technology for transform
transactions and mobile commerce
typically from a from a from a cell
phone okay from a mobile phone so that
that's that sort of technology lends
itself to saying okay there is an
existing near field communication
technology one of them for example is
called Sony FeliCa what else can we do
with it
where else can it be pushed okay good
viable way to look at the world the
first example I want to bring up for
tech pull is entirely new mental models
of authority and expertise okay I'm
older than a lot of you guys and I can
tell you that the mental constructs that
the world has are
thority and expertise have been turned
on their head in the last 15 years and
something that sociologists and
historians are going to be studying
forever
all right traditional models of
authority doctors ministers Consumer
Reports magazines okay are losing power
in favor of bottoms up ground up
authority from wiki's and blogs and
crowdsourcing I mean my God look what's
happened in Egypt okay if anybody more
than two weeks ago had any doubt about
the importance of the inversion of
authority okay look at some of these
examples public commissioning
investigative reports on spot us live
broadcasts from mobile web phones a TV
station based entirely on user created
content so this is not a technology like
a wiki or a blog or something like this
this is a fundamental human trend and it
is incumbent on us to ask ourselves all
right what technology could be brought
to bear by my organization or by the
startup I'm creating or whatever to it
you know to address this important trend
another example all the world's a
pointer okay this is not a technology
it's a trend it's a new mental construct
it's a technology driven construct
because that's what I specialize it and
we could talk about non technology
driven constructs people are expecting
they wouldn't put it to you this way but
people are expecting a virtual overlay
to the physical world and it's been
fascinating for me to see this to to
watch this grow you know ten years ago
this thing called yellow arrow was
really huge and we all thought it was
just amazing and very very cool I mean
ten years just seems to a fly by right
but the state of the art of augmented
reality ten years ago was people would
slap these yellow arrows stickers like
in front of historic buildings in New
York you would you would text message
the serial number the unique serial
number on that yellow arrow into the
yellow arrow company and you get a text
message back which allowed you to read
in just straight text about what you
were looking at it okay now ten years
later we've got things like Google
Goggles that allows you to actually hold
your phone you know up infront
of something and and see a and see a
virtual overlay to the physical world
like the ratings of a given restaurant
or something like that much of this is
enabled by cloud computing so here again
why are we bring this up we're moving
this up because this is an important
technology pull mental construct people
are going to start to think of physical
objects as tags and pointers to
cyberspace that's a very important trend
and it's only going to increase
everybody's thinking about this I'm
working with State Farm Insurance right
now we spend we spent a lot of our time
on my current project thinking about the
previous trend I described to you which
is you know the notion of what happens
to the insurance business in an era in
which authority is inverted and access
to information like actuarial tables has
become completely democratized I want to
pause there because that's the first
major thing I wanted to talk about was
this well let me just say a few more
words about tech push and tech polo just
to sum up so what are we talking about
here we're talking about managing
technologists and we're talking about
managing engineers and how engineers
need to behave on innovation programs
and so again the first point I want to
make here is that one job of an engineer
or a technologist managed by a business
person which most of you are is to help
evaluate important trends through a lens
of relevant technologies in order to
spell out business implications
large-scale social needs important
trends and so on thoughts at this point
I want to pause here thoughts on tech
push versus tech pull mixes
but it seems like when you talk about
pull a lot of it is maybe not limiting
yourself to existing technology at some
point you come up with here's a need
okay you can you can use you can use
tech pull to to drive major R&D
decisions in an organization and tech
pull lends itself better to that than
tech push tech push deals mostly with
what's out today and what the emerging
what the what the trajectories are of
saying this class of silicon chips and
these nanomaterials and so on whereas
tech pull leads you to think alright
what is it importantly we're doing
friends and what what type of
development and what sort of future
technology is required for my
organization to avail itself for those
trends yes in terms of your
technologists how do you think about
making sure that the person playing the
technology role doesn't let their own
personal toolbox define the boundaries
technology versus being curious and able
to get up speed on anything so
technology is so vast that people are
any technologist is limited by his or
her toolbox and I mean there's there are
a couple things you can do first of all
you can hire people who are
intellectually curious and open to
constantly informing themselves on all
kinds of emerging trends so even though
that is by definition a limited toolbox
people who are extremely focused and
committed to a certain type of
technology or a certain type of
implementation are incredibly important
and valuable to any organization you
need people like that but they're not
good fits for for innovation programs so
the first thing I would say is just
staff carefully right staff someone
who's loves reading The Economist
magazine and there's always interested
in in in in broadly informing himself or
herself also keep your rolodex really
fat full of experts you know I mean my
dirty little secret is a lot of what I'm
able to do is dig into my rolodex
because I've been at this for so long so
when someone needs an expert on RFID
chips I've got a guy right and when
someone needs someone who's an expert on
artificial intelligence I've got someone
else in every case what characterizes
those people is they know how to bring
interdisciplinary teams introducing
innovation teams up to a shared level of
familiarity without burying them in
technical detail that they don't
understand anyway other questions you
wanna have a wide rolodex yeah yeah and
of course that's easier easier with
these these days but you still have to
have the right kind of person you know a
good cultural fit yeah that's a very
important point because the business
people on the technical people need to
change their behavior depending on the
phase of the program your behavior is it
static anyone in the development phases
of the program or static okay no other
questions we can go into that so I guess
one here's how I like to think about
what I call the dynamic role of a
technologist and you could just as
easily call this the dynamic role of a
of a businessperson okay you're here
because a lot of you are interested in
leadership some of you already in
leadership in many cases you're going to
be managing heavily technical teams
something that has been difficult for me
and that has been a personal
transformation for me and that is
incumbent on many of the technologists
is what is is to adjust your behavior
your patterns of behavior what you say
and what you do depending on the phase
of the program how many of your
engineers in the room how many of you
have an engineering background who saw
the Tacoma Narrows video can you can you
describe it to everybody
a narrow bridge spanned a wide gets
banned nobody just that's where the
bridge crocks then the the wind hit the
natural frequency of the bridge yeah and
it started to well first of all they did
design for that but they they understood
the structural piece and they it is
designed for this resonances yeah call
it resonances so when the wind actually
everything has a oscillate and yeah I
mean the bridge is completed and it goes
crashing into this canyon below you know
the tears yeah and the rebar gets torn
open and things like that so basically
all engineers have seen this video okay
and the message behind this video is
don't let this happen to you okay be
conservative be risk-averse be safe
using safety margins and that's exactly
as it should be when you're in the
development program of the development
stage of a program if I'm driving over a
bridge with my family I want it to be
does have been designed by a
professional engineer with with with
with large safety margins okay when I
carry my laptop computer onto a plane I
wanted to have been designed by someone
who knows how to treat lithium batteries
so that they don't explode okay but that
but fundamentally engineering and I'm an
electrical engineer by training both
undergrad and grad engineering is
fundamentally a risk-averse profession
and that's the issue that needs to
change for successful and consistent
innovation here's a deal this is a very
qualitative graph that I've drawn these
are three major phases of any program
with the innovation elements highlighted
what do we do we explore we id8 and then
we develop now if this were linear this
is you know 95 percent of the project
this little block would go like all the
way through that wall out the you know
to the outside okay
but these phases these early innovation
phases are desperately important and
that's why I wanted to call them out
what's and what's important is shown
vertically and qualitatively here so
what's important when you're doing
development what matters is that you
don't have another Tacoma Narrows what
matters is that you're Bolivian battery
doesn't explode and that your bridge
doesn't fall into the canyon okay so an
attitude of feasibility and risk
mitigation which all engineers are
trained in and and the the field
attracts people who are careful and want
to mitigate risk is of prime importance
during the development phase okay
if if I come up to Luis and he's got a
circuit board that's almost done and
it's got a ship and I say to him you
know what I just discovered a new chip
that I think would do a better job for
you and I think you should switch over
to it okay I may be correct factually it
may be a better chip it may be higher
higher processing power and and use
fewer watts but it's a stupid thing to
say because we're in development okay
and we're going into regulatory testing
and we've got to get the thing out on
the market in four weeks or six weeks so
I'm saying a correct thing but at the
wrong time okay now let's talk about the
inverse of that this is where things
really go wrong involving technical
people in innovation generally
particularly in big companies a question
came up a big about around big companies
during the exploration phase as if you
are interested in leading innovation you
have got to figure out a way for people
to extend disbelief for days or weeks
during the exploration phase and in
particular you've got to figure out a
way for people to think about new
technologies new and emerging
technologies in terms of inspiration and
opportunities not in terms of the risks
that they represent okay for those of
you that are not engineers engineering
training which is important is a great
deal of it as around new risk mitigation
okay if you're asked to deliver
something you pluck out the areas of
risk if you're asked to deliver a
medical instrument you say okay the the
fluid handling system is going to be
problematic and this this you know the
sensitive analog electronics are gonna
be issue I'm gonna pluck out those risk
areas and I'm gonna worry about them and
I'm an emitting
the risks with analysis and iterative
testing and iterative prototyping that's
great that says it should be
during the early phase of a program you
need to figure out a way for technical
people and technical teams to think
about emerging technologies in terms of
the opportunity in terms of the
potential for inspiration of those
emerging technologies and not in terms
of the risks they represent okay I'm
talking about a cultural change here I'm
talking about a behavioral change that
is born of people I mean what is B what
is culture culture is the result of of
how people what people do and what they
say in a given organization I'm talking
about people saying different things and
doing different things as appropriate
during different phases of the program
so the counter example of what I
mentioned you know the sort of
hypothetical I gave with Louise is this
if during the exploration phase Louise
brings up a really exciting idea for a
mobile data service and I say you know
what there's a reason that's just never
going to work or the reason to it would
just be too expensive to develop Louise
or something like that I may be correct
okay I maybe my statement may be
rigorous and factually correct but I'm
saying at the wrong time because what I
need to do is create an environment and
with disbelief is suspended for an
extended amount of time okay if if you
allow statements like well we tried that
before and it doesn't really work
classic big company stuff right or
that's really risky or hey you know
that'll never get through management
those statements may be true but you
can't allow that during the early phases
of a program otherwise you will
definitely definitely squelch innovation
you'll never get any fresh ideas and
you'll never bring anything disruptive
to the market and then you know again
qualitatively in the middle during
ideation what you want to manage is
essentially equal importance to both of
these styles of thinking right so for
example you want to think about emerging
technology or about business risk in the
case of business to take David's
question from a little earlier you want
to think about you want to think about
those issues on one hand in terms of
opportunities and inspiration for new
products and new services and so on and
on the other hand you want to honestly
assess the risks inherent in in say the
new business model or or latching on to
some emerging technology so what are
technologists on an innovation team do
and how do I recommend you manage
technologists during the innovation
phase ok technologists should be helping
everybody on an interdisciplinary team
to understand a broad aggregation of
emerging technologies technologists and
business people David's a great example
should act as coaches and teachers to
the team if they are acting as policemen
during the early phase you're in trouble
ok
so when we developed a voice over IP
phone for Cisco I think we did an
extremely good job of doing two things
one was bringing the engineers the
scientists all the technical people as
well as the marketing and human factors
and business people out into the field
to meet with a total of about 78 users
in Europe and Asia and the US and what I
can honestly say is that some of the
reason that that some emerging
technology was built into this new phone
is because we created a careful
environment in which disbelief was
suspended during early phases and and we
look very honestly at technologies that
you know at that point we're still
emerging like a Inc the technology used
in a Kindle as candidate technologies
for the for the phone so I'd like to
hear your thoughts just about this
notion of your responsibility as leaders
to foster a certain dynamic behavior of
technologists a behavior that shifts
according to the stage of the program
that you're in it's easy to say it is
not an easy thing to do yeah
but yeah it does seem like there's a
stigma especially early on development
especially in the tech space it's a
later stage of development where they're
somehow arises a need or a realization
piece and yeah thinking more than the
first part it's a business what is the
value that you sell coaching teacher
yeah I mean if if people feel like look
I'm gonna write the best coder in the
world and then hey you're business guy
your job is to put a price on it and the
managers marketing activities okay
that's okay
but if I'm saying that to you I'm I'm
really missing a trick in terms of
innovation opportunities because if you
were around
familiarizing me with emerging emerging
web 2.0 business models and
familiarizing me with possible end
markets and and new scenarios of use of
whatever technology I'm developing that
I never even thought of it's gonna
benefit me okay if if I feel like you're
gonna cramp my style you're gonna be a
policeman you're gonna slow me down I'm
going to avoid having business people in
and I'm gonna put technology on a
pedestal and just sort of likely assume
the technology will sell itself part of
the part of the issue there is being a
t-shaped business person and having an
honest empathy and appreciation for the
pressures and responsibilities of the
technical people and part of it is
positioning yourself from the beginning
as a supportive coach and teacher
helping them to do their jobs better and
get it you know get it right the first
time
other questions yeah
and then it's a topic of programming and
because obviously resources we started
using partners yeah outside
yeah and it's a very difficult space
because you don't want to give too much
control yeah
and so it was a problem for us at
medical device company and right how do
we handle that space I don't know as far
as this sort of development curve well
that they come in a little later on so
development resources external
developments and resources come in on
the lap on the light part of that curve
okay you typically bring them in when
development is happening but other
external resources can come in really
early and my recommendation is is that
there's a unique answer for for every
organization but my my recommendation
here is every company should have a
strategy for innovation and I mentioned
this earlier there are only there only
three ways to innovate okay you can in
source you can you can in source
innovation right for those of you that
watch GE like what it was six years ago
when it all took over one of the major
initiatives he had was to shift the
innovation process to institute to try
to pump up internal and organic
processes for innovation okay
so how are you going to innovate even in
source you can outsource right you can
hire companies like us or or or McKinsey
or something like that to come up with
creative solutions for you and you can
buy innovation right you can apply your
innovation Cisco style it's a very very
successful model you can acquire you can
license you can purchase ok so that's it
for innovation and what I would say is
we'd have to get into the specifics of
your business to understand when it's
appropriate to bring in external
resources but it should be guided by a
set of strategic principles around how
you want to innovate right and I don't
consider I consider every single one of
these fair game and I could point to two
companies that do that are extremely
successful you know being ninety percent
any one of these you know I can point to
companies that do most of their most of
their innovation through in sourcing and
in through you know through internal
growth that outsource most of their
innovation to two design firms and that
and that innovate essentially by
acquisitions and allow small companies
to take the innovation risk
they're all good workable models so I
hope that helps a little bit yeah other
questions
yeah you lead by an example and you
create a culture in which there are
qualitative rewards for the right kind
of behavior I mean I think you just need
to look at simple economic style
incentives they're not it's not
literally payment you know they're
they're they're intangible incentives
but I think you just need to look at I
think you just need to look at the fact
that you need to consider I mean if
you're me you consider that human beings
are entities that respond to incentives
and if the incentives are there for a
particular type of behavior you're gonna
get it
David will tell you that I do the
incentives are there for for when
appropriate suspended extended
suspension of disbelief and if you come
off as a cynic and a naysayer in some
organizations you come off as smart
right a hardcore technical organization
lots of PhDs built on academic rigor
you know PhDs from from a from a culture
of peer review at universities if you
can if you can if you can spear someone
else's idea and show why it's wrong you
win okay
that's important an idea that comes into
you know criticism comes into it to it
but if you behave that way at the wrong
time
no one's gonna want you on the project
can I do so you get what you measure for
and you get what you award to a great
extent you can start by setting the
right example yourself as members of
leadership and organizations what else
can I tell you about
okay
I want to talk a little about synthesis
this is the third point that that that
David wanted to make sure that all of
you came away with because he thought it
was it was an interesting thing that he
had learned so let's talk about
inspiration and let's talk about let's
talk about managing that inspiration
with a process called synthesis how do
you do it first of all it's important to
define terms I defined innovation
earlier it's kind of weird how many you
know like CEOs and executives talk about
innovation as an important plank in
their strategy but can't actually define
what they mean by innovation similarly
we've talked about in sport inspiration
a lot we'll be talking about inspiration
in this section inspiration are people
or things or events that influence the
mind or the creative imagination okay
that's a very general definition that's
how we think of inspiration their people
their events their things that influence
the mind or the creative imagination now
one of the questions that came up
earlier was how can you be efficient how
can you innovate in a small organization
you've got a limited budget you're in a
hurry maybe you're creating a start-up
in your spare time and you have a full
time job here's what I think you should
keep in mind you want to be in if you
want to innovate you need to be inspired
like I mentioned earlier I know a guy
you know that that comes up with a cool
idea every eight minutes or whatever
most people aren't like that but all of
us can be creative and innovative if we
are inspired and of the sources of
inspiration I mentioned earlier by far
by far the strongest one are other human
beings face to face contact with other
human beings some of you work in b2c
businesses okay a visceral a gut level
appreciation for the needs of a diverse
base of customers not from reading white
papers not from reading market research
but from getting out in the field and
understanding how people actually live
and work and play okay is terribly
important some of you work in b2b
environments for that forget the word in
custom
and user think about your stakeholders
okay you work for a software company
it's a b2b firm you work for sa P
somebody like that fine
let's get a visceral let's get a
heartfelt appreciation for the needs of
the business decision makers and the
technical decision makers and some of
the end-users that are going to be using
our software okay
in either case what you learn out in the
field will surprise you don't kid
yourself and think that you know what
really goes on and the notion here is
very simple if we want to be inspired
let's use our ability as human beings to
listen to what people have to say and
let's look at what they do
alright let's look at how they use their
cell phones let's look at how they
interact with software let's look at how
they use emergency services and let's
use those observations of patterns of
speech and and and and modes of behavior
to project and imagine how people are
thinking and how people are feeling so I
want to distinguish when you're taking
in information early an innovation
program I want to distinguish between
classic research which is essential and
terribly important this is something
that that David did a wonderful job
commissioning from two different market
research sources at the beginning of the
program we worked on that's that's
essential background for the team but I
don't think you would say that it
inspired us it informed us and it was
important for that reason but it didn't
inspire us what inspired us was getting
out into the field speaking to crafters
and seeing how they use various types of
crafting equipment so give everybody a
minute to just read this off the screen
- to drive home the distinction between
qualitative research intended to inspire
and quantitative research intended to
inform
okay
so what's an example here
Shimano a lot of you are probably bikers
Shimano makes really nice hubs and gear
sets a lot of a lot of bike parts
Shimano asked us to think about new
opportunities in biking and one of the
things we discovered and you know when
you look back on these things obviously
into you know in retrospect you can
armchair quarterback yourself and say oh
intuitively that should have been
obvious we had no idea how many tens of
millions of Americans there were who
really want a bike they have happy
memories of bicycling when they were
kids but they're intimidated by the
state of bicycling today they're
intimidated when they walk into a bike
shop they're intimidated by the way the
bikes look the carbon-fiber book looks
they're intimidated by the ripped guy in
lycra you know that that that's selling
them the bikes and they don't want any
part of it right and so one of the
things that came up was how can we gain
how can we use needs-based
insights from the field to come up with
a new type of bike and what we came up
with in this case was what's called a
coaster bike you know and I could point
to a lot of simple little observations
this is an early sketch of one of the
bike seats
people would say look it's you know
biking seems good but it really hurts
when I have my wallet and my cell phone
so we created I can show it to you an
idea we created a bike seat that opens
up with just enough room for a wallet in
the cell phone so you can take those out
of your pocket and stick them into the
bike seat you know and there are a whole
lot of little things like that the the
the the brakes are not hand brakes you
just pedal backwards to brake there's an
automatic transmission which was Astra
mono technology which adjusts the torque
which adjusts the gear the gearing ratio
based on the torque on the on the and
the chain and so on so what the point
that I want to make is that the the the
coaster bikes which they came out with
were entirely inspired by field research
that we did there weren't any white
papers or anything that told us hey
there are 10 million American tens of
millions of Americans that are
intimidated by the state of biking and
that wants something simpler I don't
know how we would have come to this I
don't know how we would have come to
this observation or the order this can
without without going out in the field
so now let's talk about synthesis this
is the last point that David wanted me
to make and I wanted to talk about how
we gather information before I talk
about synthesis so let's imagine that
we've done what I described right you've
created a small team of t-shaped people
you have a voice of the human you have
the you know the voice of the user you
have the voice of business or policy and
you have the voice of technology you've
gone out in the field you've read some
white papers you've talked to experts
you've you've done some field research
and again to the question that came up
earlier about about innovating on
limited means this can be done very
quickly and very inexpensively this is
I'm not talking about commissioning six
months of research the type of
activities I'm talking about here take
weeks not months what's next the next
thing to do is to use your inspiration
to visualize possibilities and that's
the idea of synthesis so here's the
here's the premise if we want to
innovate if we want to come up with
something new we're gonna take in a lot
of concrete data so if this is time and
this is relatively more concrete
information and this is more abstract
we're gonna take in a lot of data some
of it is intended to inspire some of it
is intended to inform whatever the case
it's a bunch of tangible inputs okay
what do we want to come out with we want
to come out with concepts that win in
the market people miss apply qualitative
needs based user research of the sort
that I described a little earlier you
need to be careful of this people draw a
short circuit from here to here okay I
guarantee you it won't work if if Luis
is trying to come up with a new software
package for the medical instruments that
he's that his company is developing
if he asks stakeholders what they need
and some one person says well I need a
different kind of home screen and
someone else's I need this sort of
button if he takes that stuff literally
these inputs literally and he just uses
them to create an engineering
requirement spec and implement some
things aren't gonna work
you must veer into a layer of
abstraction in order to innovate
successfully okay and that's what
synthesis is synthesis says let's take
all the inputs that we've gained in
trying to understand what the
opportunities are like and you are doing
your job right if you get divergent
inputs if one person says this home
screen is too complicated and the other
says it's too simple it needs more
features you're doing your job right
because you're finding these
irreconcilable differences and it's
going to be your job to reconcile them
and to and to find a happy medium
between them okay so here are the inputs
this is the process of synthesis leads
to insights which in turn leads to
design principles which in turn leads to
concepts what are some examples of each
of these okay
the insights that David and I put
together and the rest of the team on
this crafting project were this we
created some personas who are amalgams
of some of the most common and
consistent user needs that we saw in the
field for five different types of
crafters okay and we identified two of
those personas as targets it's a fairly
common marketing method right we
identified two of those personas as
ideal targets for the organization okay
you know the insights for the bike
project that I showed earlier had to do
with the the hesitation that so many
Americans felt about biking okay from
the insights you come up with design
principles and then you know that the
concepts that you come up with have been
guided by a synthesized set of inputs so
our the point of our talk is about the
how of innovation how do you synthesize
all right so here we are there's seven
of us right and we're trying to and
we're trying to get all of our all of
our insights into some kind of
actionable form
so what's synthesis synthesis says let's
take all this input let's find direction
and make meaning from all this disparate
input that we've got so I will tell you
exactly how we do it an I do and I you
know obviously I'm not saying that you
should graph this method into your
organization but what you may want to do
is is take some of the general
principles and apply them as appropriate
take a you know three to five person
innovation team say everybody in this
first row we all sit together having
done some field research we've read some
white papers we've gone out in the field
and we've talked to stakeholders take
post-it notes we our goal other issues
aside at I do is to keep 3m in business
with post with with you know keep them
in business with post-it notes each of
us writes down key points and key in
it's our our key insights rather from
the research that we've done okay
so David's met somebody in the field he
writes down six eight ten signature
details of that individual to help us
understand who that person is the single
best way to be inspired is to meet
someone in the field who's a potential
user of your product or service
a close second is to have your colleague
who's due who did the same research off
the same research plan tell you about
the person they met show you a digital
camera image of who it is and put a
bunch of notes up in much the same way
that a novelist never gives you a
complete you know extended labored
picture of a character in a novel a
novelist gives you a few carefully
chosen key signature details that add up
to a complete and holistic picture you
want to try to do the same thing you
want to try to give the signature
details of the people that you met so
that we really understand who they are
how they're behaving what their
motivations are questions like what are
their attitudes towards technology what
are much media they consume these these
sorts of things okay
so step one is absorb the stories okay
yeah um and tell stories from the field
so in this case the six of us say would
put post-it notes on the wall we'd cover
you know potentially all these walls
sharing with each other who we saw in
the field okay there's not it's not a
lengthy process next the best I can tell
you the best thing I can tell you in
synthesis is look for repetition okay
let's imagine that in aggregate all of
this this group here meets sixteen
people total you think how could you
possibly base a major decision on
sixteen people the answer is you choose
the right people you choose a set of
attributes that are important to you
orthogonal attributes of people okay
typical attributes might be age of life
stage socioeconomic level attitudes
towards technology you know are they and
then you get into more specifics are
they heavy media consumers are they
crafters
you know do they have high engagement or
low engagement with money whatever it is
and then we might decide that David is
going to go out in the field and he's
gonna find a senior citizen who has ha
who has a lot of knowledge about
technology but very very low engagement
with media okay that's a rather
interesting profile by searching a
specific a sufficiently broad set of
people even if it's a rather small
number you would be amazed how often
quantitative research performed with a
thousand or more people often bears out
the results of qualitative research and
I'll tell you that with say eight or ten
or sixteen well chosen people who are
orthogonal to each other across a number
of attributes right they're distinct
from each other around a number of
personal attributes I'll tell you what
if you visually if you've if you've met
12 people in the field and you're trying
to innovate for them all and you and you
identify a particular theme or
opportunity or area of interest of say
eight or nine of those twelve that is
significant that matters forget the fact
that it's not statistically significant
it's it's important all right so that's
all to justify step two which is
identifying patterns next extract the
key insights so now we're out here now
we're thinking about insights and design
principles this is really really hard
because you feel like whatever you're
coming away with is really trite we did
a project we worked for six weeks doing
research for a west for a southern south
korean telecom called SK Telecom on the
use of of how mobile phones could serve
the needs of tourists pleasure travelers
better okay did research in Asia Western
Europe us tons of synthesis one of the
one of the insights that we presented to
them we stood up and said there is an
underserved appetite for authentic and
personalized travel advice of course
there is what a ridiculous and trite
thing to say but the fact is there was
lots of thinking and lots of interviews
and lots of information gathering behind
that and the insight was sent
essentially a headline you know or the
tip of an iceberg to a lot of knowledge
that had been gained by the team last
point I want to make this speaks to this
issue that came up about innovating in
big companies
after your message okay it's tempting to
believe that having done field research
and synthesis and some brainstorming and
identified an exciting direction it's
tempting to believe that the idea will
sell itself and that people will
immediately see the benefits of the idea
this particularly happens if you're
personally excited about your idea okay
guess what that doesn't happen and the
message needs to be crafted in an
appropriate way for what I'm telling you
here powerpoints a good message
PowerPoint isn't always the right way to
go sometimes you want to pay a graphic
artist just Sketch up a storyboard to
describe the key touch points of a new
service okay sometimes you want to film
a quick video to simulate the actual
experience you're describing sometimes
you want to bring in someone who's an
expert in flash the software - to
assemble a simulation okay but just be
aware that crafting the message
particularly in a large company where
things has to go through layer after
layer of management and tollgate review
after tollgate review
crafting a message isn't terribly is
terribly important the last point I'll
make quickly is synthesis leads very
naturally into brainstorming okay I
don't think brainstorming is a very good
idea in the earliest stages of the
program because you don't know where the
opportunities are yet if we're gonna ask
6-8 people to get together in to
brainstorm and a brainstorm is a
structured means of rapid idea
generation we want to make sure that we
have an appropriate target we want to
make sure that we've got a framework of
opportunities and we've done our needs
based research so we have an idea of
where to focus people's attention hey we
want everybody to brainstorm on this
sort of next-generation data service hey
we want to for everybody to focus on on
this approach to clinics in emerging
economies whatever it is all right one
quick example from I mean I couldn't
tell you in 20 years an idea the coolest
project I've ever worked on but I can
tell you the biggest honor and it was
this for sure a quick example of
observation leading into synthesis was a
program for NASA on how to improve
spacesuits they call them they said you
know can you can you work with us to
help understand how to improve
spacesuits for the next generation of
lunar and Martian exploration and
I kind of thought well yeah I'm willing
to work on that
so I told NASA that the work had to be
done on our terms that is it had to be
done using ideas approach to to
innovation and we needed to speak to
multiple stakeholders and just to cut to
the chase I walked into a room it was
about this size and I couldn't really
believe it until I actually showed up
that we were able to coordinate all this
with the help of leadership at NASA we
got astronauts from three generations of
space travel we got men who walked on
the moon men who were in Skylab in the
70s and people who and and men and women
who had been to the International Space
Station
we even got this dapper guy in his 70s
who designed the spacesuits for the
Apollo astronauts he was the design
engineer and his name true story is Joe
Cosmo
I just love okay so this is an example
of of the innovation process in action
spacesuits are a disaster when I got
into one the only thing you can think of
when you get into a space suit is how
soon you can get out of the thing
picture a ski boot not a snowboarding
boot but for those of you that have
parallel ski in a ski boot that doesn't
fit you and then like extend that over
your whole body it's like the worst
feeling you can possibly imagine you
know or if you wear contact lenses
imagine a contact a hard contact lens
with a piece of dust under it where all
you can think about is getting it out of
your eye okay that's how a spacesuit
feels and just to cut to the chase was a
wonderful program one of the things we
concluded was that in the 10 plus year
time frame material science was still a
long ways away from solving the
challenge of creating something that was
more comfortable had improved
situational awareness and was safer in
consideration of all the things a
spacesuit has to do it has to be a
pressure vessel that has to keep
astronauts cool when they're in the Sun
warm when they're in the shade it needs
micrometeorite protection it needs to
provide air and and
nutrients it has to monitor a lot of
physiological processes and the through
the process of talking to astronauts and
through the process of brainstorming
with them and being art-directed by them
the particular insight in this case was
you know we can make some improvements
to spacesuits but the really the right
answer is to create something that
provides a lot of the most important
attributes of a spacesuit like
situational awareness but allows
astronauts to work in a shirtsleeve
environment so what we came up with was
a these are some of the early sketches
that we made of a very small pressurized
Rover that would allow astronauts to
work inside of it but would allow them
to slip in and out of the spacesuits
very very quickly in 10 minutes rather
than the hour that that later takes
today and if you saw some of the
sketches a second ago you can see if you
look at the actual prototype on the Left
it's it's being presented at President
Obama's inauguration on the right it's
being tested in Arizona you can see that
the the actual prototype is pretty close
to some of the earliest sketches that we
made as a result of brainstorming and
synthesis with this with his team of of
astronauts so I'm gonna stop there I'd
like to know what questions you have or
comments you have about the process of
synthesis yeah yes
yeah so the in general if you're
outsourcing professional services the
more upstream you are the more upstream
your outsourcing activity is the more
what we call radical collaboration is
essential so I agree with that statement
if the professional services are managed
wrong okay if the founders of a start-up
commissioned a market research firm to
identify the market come up with some
concepts and then come back with quote
unquote the answer and they disappear
for six weeks and come back with
something I guarantee I without knowing
any more details I guarantee you it'll
be a failure okay the only way to
outsource successfully on early upstream
programs is through what we call radical
collaboration and what distinguishes
radical collaboration from other types
of collaboration is this in radical
collaboration and innovation programs
shared generative activities occur okay
what that means is that in the start in
the in the in the in the in the
hypothetical you just gave the startup
identifies particular points of
engagement with the firm that they've
outsourced some innovation activities to
they spent a day with them two days
three days at all the key points all
right and if you go on that shared
process of discovery they're gonna be
okay
it's when external entities go open loop
during early stages that you get into
problem this rule doesn't apply once you
get more into implementation right you
can we have successfully created
engineering requirements specs and
detailed specifications ship those
overseas and gotten very good code back
from people that we've never met
okay that's possible once things are
unambiguous and define early in the
process it isn't so back to specifics if
you think about these phases I've just
described we always include our clients
going into the field with us to do the
field research okay we included them and
they have what we call a seat at the
synthesis table they're sitting with us
in brain storms that's that's essential
other questions and I think what would
me just say on those terms I don't agree
with what the with what the gentleman
said this morning but given an open-loop
situation where you just commissioned
research and people walk away and do it
I agree if you're gonna run it that way
then the founders of the organization
really need to one last question is a
group and then I can I can say yeah I
think so I think so I'm wondering if you
could since working at IDEO you're
coming from a consulting angle yeah so
yeah then problem definition in the
school of your design projects is
essential right
yes and I'm wondering if you were to put
take off the I do hat beyond the
entrepreneur hat yeah you don't have a
client coming to you how you would think
about scoping your project yeah at the
start and it's not brought you all yeah
yeah I would take a cue from venture
capitalists when you guys talk to ninja
capitalists all the time every venture
capitalist has a different approach many
of their approaches are very divergent
there is only one thing that every
single VC anywhere that you'll ever meet
in the world agrees on which is this
so if I take off my ido hat and I and I
and I leave I do today and I started a
business I start with a right team I
start with an interdisciplinary team of
people with a track record of success
and preferably people who have if we're
talking about a start-up people who have
provided returns to - venture
capitalists in the past right you got a
team of people that have two successful
startups under their belt and have
returned handsome returns to venture
capitalists in the past that means
something about that team of individuals
so you first of all you identify a team
that can execute that's fundamental
that's basic that's table stakes I would
happily choose a team of people that can
execute with no product concept over
something with a you know a team I felt
less good about but an idea that excited
me okay next thing down right you
identify the market let's identify the
right market let's identify a market
with the right dynamics it's got to be
growing and it's got a support in many
cases it's got a support value pricing
okay we don't want to enter something
commodity and after that let's think
about the product let's think about the
concept knowing that most VCS don't pay
that much attention to the concept they
know the basic concept could easily
morph three or five or seven times
during the first years of the startups
existence but they're confident that a
good that a good team will get them
there so that's what that's what I would
do